[Música]
eu tenho que confessar uma coisa eu
tenho um patrimônio acumulado o meu
patrimônio acumulado
são mais de 150 roteiros diferentes pela
cidade do rio de janeiro
o meu patrimônio acumulado são mais de
10 mil pessoas impactadas o meu
patrimônio acumulado é um prémio de
empreendimento sustentável
eu sou apaixonada pelo turismo e foi por
isso que em 2015
eu me criei para essa área e eu entendi
dentro desse mundo do turismo que os
moradores de uma cidade
eles podem sim ser considerados turistas
na sua própria cidade
vocês devem estar achando que eu pirei
mas eu não pirei está tudo em dia eu vou
fazer um teste aqui com vocês
quantos de vocês eu peço que levantem a
mão e sejam super sinceros
quantos de vocês já fizeram fizeram uma
visita mediada na casa cláudio de souza
eu vi três mãos levantadas só para vocês
saberem quantas pessoas aqui já fizeram
uma visita mediada no palácio rio negro
a um pouco mais vocês olharam ao redor
de vocês viram quantas pessoas
levantaram as mãos não é pra sentir
vergonha isso acontece de fato isso
acontece em cidades que são consideradas
turísticas
normalmente uma pessoa ela sequer
conhece um terço do local de moradia
mas por que será que isso acontece
eu tenho algumas teorias e soluções e
como me convidaram porque acharam que a
minha idéia merece ser compartilhada eu
tenho que compartilhar com vocês e
talvez plantar uma sementinha nesse
coraçãozinho de gelo
se você for
mariano como eu a minha primeira teoria
é que as agências de turismo não vêem o
morador como potencial cliente
bom isso é pura verdade uma agência de
turismo
ele tem como pode como cliente principal
o turista e de acordo com a oms ter
organização mundial do turismo o turista
é aquela pessoa que se desloca do seu
local de origem para outro local seja
ele a lazer ou a negócios mas que fique
num período menor do que um ano mas que
incrível seria setas secretaria de
turismo que essas agências de turismo e
todos esses fornecedores do mercado de
turismo entendessem que esses moradores
são cinco potenciais clientes
imagina que incrível seria se a cidade
de petrópolis não depender se totalmente
da alta temporada
eu tô falando de alta temporada que em
petrópolis é o inverno todo mundo quer
subir em junho e julho para comer o que
um fondue ir é eu também faço isso mas e
os outros meses de janeiro fevereiro e
março a cidade de petrópolis livre de
inverno e power feche e aí o que
acontece mas outros lugares nos outros
meses nada está errado
esses guias de turismo que trabalham
aqui na cidade
nesta alta temporada fazendo o que na
baixa não têm trabalho mas a gente
precisa criar essa demanda
a gente precisa começar a criar essa
demanda a oferta turística
essa é a primeira teoria a minha segunda
teoria é que as agências de turismo tem
medo de arriscar
se você for em qualquer agência que
tenha cidade de petrópolis no seu
portfólio chegar lá e perguntar e aí
tudo bem faz petrópolis
faço o que está incluso no roteiro
querido até incluso museu imperial está
incluso catedral de são pedro está
incluso o palácio de cristal ea casa são
tudo bom não podemos esquecer
ok é claro que esses lugares precisam
estar dentro desse contexto histórico
eles são importantes fazem parte da
cidade é claro mas e se essa pessoa já
veio para petrópolis mais de uma vez
significa que ela já viu tudo na cidade
não significa que as empresas de turismo
não estão vendo todo esse potencial da
cidade de petrópolis
lembra da do palácio rio negro que eu
falei pra vocês
olha que incrível seria se uma agência
fizesse um roteiro falando do período
republicano em plena cidade imperial dá
pra fazer o palácio rio negro ele foi
residência de veraneio dos presidentes
quando a nossa capital é o rio de
janeiro
ou então ainda utilizar casa cláudio de
souza com um roteiro incrível uma visita
mediada um sarau e torna isso uma
experiência
ontem o passeio em frente estava tendo
um sarau vocês sabiam não isso não é
divulgado
as agências de turismo tem medo de
arriscar
elas acham que ninguém quer comprar
aquilo que não é padronizado
o que a gente precisa entender é que
esses espaços antigos precisam ter novos
olhares
essa foi a segunda teoria a minha
terceira é que nós sofremos com a
síndrome de vira lata e quando eu digo
nós eu me incluo nessa
eu vou contar uma história rápido aqui
pra vocês em 2012
eu ea minha melhor amiga paula uma das
que se não eles vão ficar todas com
ciúme
paula uma das uma das ou dois melhores
amigas paula
nós fizemos uma viagem incrível pela
europa foram 35 dias sete países
muita energia no coração e pouco o euro
no bolso brasileiro nas lentes e aí
beleza nós somos viajamos eu voltei e
quando eu voltei eu comecei a
compartilhar a seguinte informação
gente vocês sabiam que londres é
incrível
vocês sabiam
que lá tem um quadrilátero onde tem
vários museus um do lado do outro e
todos são gratuitos
eu comecei a compartilhar isso por
várias e várias e várias vezes e aí eu
comecei a pensar do jeito que eu estou
falando não é possível que uma cidade
enorme como o rio de janeiro não tenha
atrativos culturais ou museus e
aparelhos turísticos que sejam gratuitos
ou de baixo custo e existem
e aí eu comecei a me desafiar pois é eu
fiz uma planilha eu virei a louca da
planilha da gente no ascendente é virgem
eu virei a louca da planilha eu fui
planilhar tudo e aí eu descobri que
tinham mais de cem mais de cem museus e
centros culturais que eu nunca sequer
tinha ouvido falar
aí vem o desafio é aí ferrou eu fui
querer conhecer um por um e eu fui a
replicadora disso eu fui falar para os
meus amigos e dos meus familiares que
existiam aqueles espaços porque a
secretaria de turismo não fazem isso
porque as agências de turismo muito
menos
então eu era esse agente de mudança na
minha própria cidade porque eu comecei a
entender esse espaço
eu comecei a me apropriar daquilo e
empoderado lugar que eu moro
eu fico impressionada com algumas
pessoas que falam assim nossa eu fui pra
paris foi visitá o lucro foi incrível
tirei foto com a mona lisa gente a mona
lisa é desse tamanho está não querem é
tirar as expectativas não sei não mas é
pequeno com um pequeno spoiler aqui e aí
essas mesmas pessoas ou a grande maioria
delas que foram visitar o louvre se quer
botar os pés no museu nacional que foi
devastado pelo fogo no ano passado
vocês têm ideia disso vocês têm idéia é
que a gente perdeu um dos nossos maiores
patrimônios aqui no rio de janeiro e que
isso pode acontecer em qualquer momento
porque que acontece
porque a gente não se apropria desses
lugares porque a gente não sem poder há
porque a gente não tem orgulho do lugar
onde a gente mora
esse orgulho não é criado na gente desde
criança não é mesmo
a gente é muito convidado a conhecer a
história do outro a segunda guerra
mundial
nossa a gente saiba tudo o nazismo
sabemos também mas ea guerra de uma lei
a revolta das vacinas a gente não sabe a
gente passa muito rápido por isso na
nossa escola e é super verdade e quando
a gente não visita esses patrimônios
quando a gente não se empoderar desses
lugares a gente não cria uma conexão com
aquilo então passa a ser não é
importante mas é isso que a gente quer é
isso que a gente quer que aconteça
novamente que esse fogo device todos os
outros aparelhos culturais que a gente
tem não não é isso que a gente quer
eu não tô aqui pra isso eu não vim aqui
nesse mundo pra isso eu vim pra
compartilhar informação a bia falou
sobre propósito meu propósito é esse é
passar pra vocês aquilo que eu sei e é o
que a minha equipe sabe que é uma equipe
incrível de 25 guias de turismo que
estão prontos ali para compartilhar
informação da cidade para os moradores
da cidade dos nossos principais clientes
não são turistas nossos principais
clientes são sim esses moradores
eu não sei se vocês sabem mas petrópolis
significa a cidade de pedro ii mas hoje
aqui nesse exato lugar e para quem
estiver assistindo esse toque
a cidade hoje não é de pedro
a cidade hoje é da gabi é da adriana é
da iara é da solange é da ana é da bia é
de todo mundo que tá assistindo isso se
aproprie do espaço que você mora
tenha orgulho disso sem poder e desses
lugares porque só assim a gente vai
poder compartilhar boas notícias dos
conseguir vender a nossa cidade porque
eu só consigo vender aquilo que eu
conheço
então saia dessa estatística saia da
estatística que levantou só três mãos
vamos virar esse jogo vamos entender
esse espaço e se apropriar dele muito
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]